I want to talk about this one story what
Tucker said
just three weeks ago which is which is
kind of weird and why would America be
interested in this uh it's a story of um
Tucker Carlson calls out CIA and YouTube
for interfering in Brazil's election
talk across and questioned the narrow
presidential election and revealed that
YouTube announced it will be censoring
any post that raised doubts about the
vote total so not only Brazilians are
not allowed to question the election
results but neither are Americans
YouTube said they are expanding their
existing election Integrity policy to
prohibit uh content advancing false
claims that widespread fraud errors or
glitches occurred in 2022 election
presidential election Carlson also
accused the CIA of interfering in the
Brazilian election for over a year and
pressuring President bolsonaro's office
to not question the election results
Biden the CIA director personally per
share pressured bolsonaro's office to
accept the results of the election long
before the election took office why is
America so interested in Brazilian
Brazil's election I have a different
view of what happened there tell us so
this is what happened I believe Roy or
Associated Press publish a story about
this okay saying that the CIA director
he was in Brazil and that he pressured
bolsonaro directly this is a Reuters
article I think he's a right guy either
either writers or Associated Press would
what's the difference there's the same
yep mainstream leftist okay uh press
agencies uh one of them published this
story The goal of the story was to put
pressure on bolsonaro on the
International Community so he would
accept the results
so when the story broke out I contacted
my sources in in the bolsonaro's
administration and all of them said what
this is this never happened we talked
but we never even mentioned elections
this never happened I don't know where
this reporter uh came up with the story
and and and that was
and and of course CIA denied it because
it would be very weird for the CIA
the diplomacy doesn't work like that and
if bolsonaro received
something like that he would probably
tell the CIA director to go I don't know
somewhere else
and and I found very weird so that's why
I checked in both sides at night but
then Bernie Sanders in the U.S Senate
mentioned it
he mentions that the story
so then when he mentions the story the
story became a fact because it's now on
the Senate's
records Okay so I believe that was not
actually and the the guy that talked to
to Tucker was very good reporter Matthew
tiermann good friend of mine
um he's a very good reporter and I think
he he was accurate the way he reported
on Tucker uh but I don't believe this
was actually the ca putting pressure on
bolsonaro I believe that was the Press
making up that the CIA was putting
pressure and then
the Democrats using the article to put
more pressure and pass something on the
I believe they pass emotion yes in the
Senate that being said we have a
left-wing government in U.S right now
Biden he was one of the first to
recognize the results and congratulate
Lula so what I think is going on is that
we need to go back to the beginning the
premise
bolsonaro in in the International
Community the mainstream politicians all
left wing all globalists bolsonaries
like Trump and both are fascists both
are a threat to democracy so they they
came up with this narrative and then
they believe in it and uh come on you
need to recognize the results are you
gonna accept it are you gonna accept or
not they are putting pressure because
they they know what's going on so with
all the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright guess your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
or black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hats
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]